- d'altrad lui n'a pas de yacht il
préfère les quêtes
al yom
et à 67 ans le milliardaire en possède
deux c'est plus pratique
en fait il faut pas le considérer comme
un comme un luxe c'est un outil de
travail
rien d'autre en vingt points c'est une
saab a besoin il presque et nécessité
d'origine syrienne mohammed altrad est
arrivé en france il ya 50 ans sans un
sou en poche
aujourd'hui c'est la 61e fortunes
françaises
il est à la tête d'une multinationale du
btp qu'il a créée de toutes pièces
son groupe fabrique échafaudages des
bétonnières chiffre d'affaires plus d'un
milliard d'euros c'est le leader mondial
cent quinze filiales réparties dans le
monde entier
une belle réussite qui démarre dans le
sud de la france près de montpellier
c'est dans cette région qu'il a élu
domicile à l'âge de 17 ans à l'époque
mohed altrad vivait modestement
aujourd'hui il possède un domaine de
trois hectares avec bâtiment d'exception
et les voitures de luxe
lamborghini et ferrari donc c'est très
peu utilisé mais je suis pas un amateur
de vitesse mais juste pour l'esthétique
juste voir la forme
ovo l'élégance de la chose vous les
conduisent déjà mais si chacun des
iphone de 3000km pas plus que ça
il y a aussi les piscines deux en
extérieur et une autre à l'intérieur
avec hammam et jacuzzi
autant de signes extérieurs de richesse
et de réussite
pour autant il y a une chose sur
laquelle le milliardaire ne transige
jamais c'est l'éducation de ses enfants
s'est achevé le père de famille ne
plaisante qu'à moitié
lui il n'a pas eu autant de chance est
en jeune mais en syrie dans une tribu de
nomades ils ne découvrent l'école qu'à
dix ans et c'est à force de travail
qu'il décroche son bac et une bourse
pour étudier en france
un tournant dans sa vie
ça c'est je venais d'arriver en france a
fait beaucoup de chemin c'est sûr ça
ressemble pas à ce que je suis
aujourd'hui c'est sûr se trouve c'est
quand même le départ
parti de rien le patron a installé son
siège dans sa propriété il partage
aujourd'hui les fruits du succès de son
groupe avec ses employés il leur verse
20 % des bénéfices de la compagnie parmi
les clés de succès voilà les clés de
succès dans gros comme ça
et bien c'est c'est d'accepter qu'une
partie de ce bénéfice revient au salage
culpabilité ou fibre sociale
il finance aussi nombre d'associations
comme le club de rugby de sa ville
montpellier
un investissement à perte
philanthropie ou besoin d'asseoir sa
notoriété pour lui c'est un juste retour
des choses on peut pas s'enrichir dans
un pays et dans le même temps refusé de
rendre une partie de cette richesse
parce que c'est pas la règle de jeu et à
l'image de rugby il faut jouer loyal et
pas jouer déloyale
comme oy d'altrad 12 nouveaux français
sont entrés dans le club très sélect des
milliardaires l'année dernière en tout
il y en a 67 dans l'hexagone
notre pays compte même près de deux
millions de millionnaires et certains
experts prédisent qui seront près du
double dans quatre ans contrairement aux
idées reçues on peut devenir riche en
france l'un des derniers à avoir franchi
ce cap le seuil du million c'est lui
steve burggraf il est entrepreneur c'est
tous les jours comme ça je pars entre 7h
7h15 et quand je démarre j'ai toujours
l'impression d'être en retard moi je
connais pas beaucoup de gens qui
réussissent sont beaucoup de travail et
des marais d'eau on démarre avec une
petite longueur d'avancé
il travaille 6 jours sur 7 après d
affaire malheureuse il a monté cette
chaîne de restaurants de burgers de luxe
il a créé en moins de trois ans tout ça
ça par pur de restaurants
l'idée c'est ici tout est artisanal et
aujourd'hui à 150 personnes dans le
société et on était trois il ya trois
ans on n'est pas une start-up d'internet
on est une start up de la bouffe
aujourd'hui son affaire pèse 12 millions
d'euros
moubarak et le peuple est la fille du
seigneur des seniors garçons i sing la
star c'est lui
et quand on ouvre la poitrine et griller
les herbes fâche c'est lui qui lui plaît
vivent 12 euros le burger tout de même
mais ces dix restaurants ne
désemplissent pas alors style de rap de
talent est encore plus loin la france
doit pas être montrés du doigt comme un
pays où les 18,6 d'entreprendre ya ben
attia voyez le bon tiens aujourd'hui
entre temps il y a matière à dès qu'on a
les idées qu'on met le travail derrière
la force la volonté ya matière à partout
et en france aussi
cet après midi le nouveau roi du
hamburger français a rendez-vous à
l'ouest de paris sur ce chantier une
zone commerciale qui devrait ouvrir dans
quelques mois l'entrepreneur envisage
d'installer un nouveau restaurant un
emplacement à 350000 euros
il a aussi l'ambition de se développer à
londres et à hong kong
cette marque le plus de pays possible
voilà on se plaint toujours de la france
maintenant on va se servir de la france
pour les produits un travailleur acharné
qui commencent à profiter de sa fortune
le dimanche à chantilly avec sa compagne
oh
il vient de s'offrir de chevaux de
course dont il ne veut pas dévoiler le
prix gémeaux nice est la première la
première qu'on a acheté la hogra doute
là qui va commencer à courir
on espère cette année son argent il
investit dans sa passion aujourd'hui il
fait partie des happy few
une belle réussite mais teintée par la
peur de perdre sa mise
on voit la réussite fulgurante mais
aussi les chutes sont fulgurantes aussi
réussir c'est bien mais froidure et
surtout ça qui est complet en fait
ça y est steve burggraf élancé au galop
sur la route de la fortune mais au fait
c'est quoi être riche c'est une notion
très relative car il ya toujours plus
riche que soit l'échelle des revenus
donne quelques indications
un enseignant par exemple avec dix ans
d'ancienneté gagne 2200 euros par mois
net
il fait partie des 26 % de français les
mieux payés
le médecin généraliste lui touche 5700
euros nets mensuels
il appartient aux 3 % les mieux
rémunérés quant aux notaires avec 13000
euros par mois il figure dans les 0,4
pour cent les mieux payés et puis tout
en haut de l'échelle
il y a les grands patrons les artistes
renommés les sportifs de haut niveau qui
gagnent en moyenne 200 mille euros
chaque mois ils ne sont que 0,003 % des
français soit 1500 personnes en principe
plus on gagne plus on paye des impôts en
proportion de son revenu
mais ça n'est pas le cas grâce aux
niches fiscales qui permettent de
réduire son taux d'imposition acheter un
cheval une oeuvre d'art un château ou
mieux encore en hérite et hubert de
moroges n'a rien fait pour procéder à
une telle demeure du xviie siècle
il est juste bien née
à une bonne chose mais ça c'est sympa
il vit avec sa femme à et fiat
un petit village près de vichy dans le
centre de la france
ça semble cette propriété est dans sa
famille depuis cinq générations
c'est mon grand père qui était officier
de cavalerie
on a ici hubert hubert de moroges mon
arrière-grand-père un peu rustique ce
château vaudrait entre 2 et 3 millions
et quand on lui demande si ce sont
riches j'ai pas grand chose et pas de
fortune personnelle si vous voulez pas
fortune elle est là donc les étaler au
grand jour
c'est du patrimoine sais pas il n'y a
pas de liquidités c'est que du
patrimoine avec un tel patrimoine
le châtelain devrait payer l'impôt sur
la fortune
pourtant il n'en est rien ce château est
classé et en france une loi donne aux
propriétaires de monuments historiques
de substantiels avantages fiscaux tous
les coûts d'entretien sont déduits de sa
feuille d'impôts ce château est un petit
paradis fiscal à lui tout seul
aujourd'hui hubert de morhange a rendez
vous avec son notaire qui gère son
patrimoine avec un peu d'astuce et le
bon conseil on cote échapper à l'impôt
aujourd'hui il s'inquiète des droits de
succession que devront payer ses trois
enfants alors hubert de moroges a décidé
de leur faire une donation de son vivant
il peut léguer à chaque enfant
cent mille euros de patrimoine tous les
15 ans sans payer un centime au fisc
l'idée c'est de rentrer dans un système
où on à la taxe la moins importante
possible restant complètement dans la
légalité
c'est ça alors évidemment si elle était
vraiment importante ce serait mieux en
faire déjà aujourd'hui c'est un système
intéressant
hubert de morges se contente d'une
optimisation fiscale en france
difficile de partir avec son château sur
le dos pour d'autres c'est plus facile
genève au bord du lac léman
on y retrouve nombre de fortunés
m
comme marc chatila il est joaillier
d'origine libanaise
en france quand on regarde la carte de
l'extérieur on le voit avec une belle
voiture quand on fait un égal voyons
fait un égal à 1 c'est pas normal donc
son argent il l'a fait illégalement aux
impasses
il partage sa vie entre la belgique et
la confédération helvétique où il a
installé ses bureaux
sa fortune est évaluée à plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros
il la doit en partie à ces bijoux qu'il
vend dans le monde entier donc c'est une
période qui vaut à peu près dans les
médias c'est des grosses pierres de
poires top top qualité aujourd'hui
notamment beaucoup de clients du
moyen-orient mais aussi des
collectionneurs et surtout le meilleur
ami des femmes il y a dix ans il
habitait en france mais après les
bisbilles avec le fisc il a jeté
l'épongé
le problème que nous avions cet écueil
vous connaît très très bien les lois
françaises il faut connaître les tenants
et les aboutissants
le travail a été très bien sauf que un
jour l'eau tout bascule ils m'ont collé
un abus de biens sociaux qui m'a fait
valoir deux ans de bataille de travail
et pour que pau à la fin à être blanchi
de tous les côtés
aujourd'hui le joaillier a diversifié
ses affaires dans l'immobilier et les
nouvelles technologies
son groupe emploie 380 personnes
une réussite loin de l'hexagone ce qui
ne l'empêchent pas d'y revenir
régulièrement
souvent après pas d'avenir
et sur paris j'aime beaucoup
la france est
moi elles apprendront histoire d'amour
histoire d'amour pour les vacances pas
pour les affaires
direction megève en haute-savoie pour
repérer un chalet
eh bien merci quinze minutes de vol pour
se retrouver dans un décor de rêve au
sommet d'une montagne dans ce chalet
haut de gamme avec cinq chambres et le
confort digne d'un grand palace
j'avais magnifique comme ça je lis
beaucoup d'histoires
tu vois maintenant surtout redoubla et
tout ça tu parles c'est une histoire de
passer au gers à l'envoi en fait eric la
qualité est resté les valeurs sont
restées on peut encore lâché boucher
acheter une bonne viande y avoir le
plaisir de parler que boucher c'est ça
qui compte
un luxe et une authenticité que les
grandes fortunes ne trouve nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde à 28000 euros la
semaine